[Music]
[Music]
tell me about this dress
jaymund oh and I'm pretty I'm a pretty
big fan
we wanted something grand for the carpet
it's such an exciting night Josh and I
are both so happy to be hearing it to
celebrate the Tonys we are just a couple
of theater kids who feel like we got
invited to the cool kids party why do
you go with a purple suit I mean you're
making a statement host I put it on and
I said let's do this it's one of those
things where you know you put it on and
you just you just feel great feel great
so you say go for it hosting an awards
show that's a lot of pressure especially
when you love the community so much and
the theater community has really changed
my life in a huge way and so we just
really want to honor them and make them
feel loved we are first and foremost for
such fans of the people we get to host
in front of tonight we're fans of this
season and we both have been embraced by
this community in a way that has been so
surprising and wonderful to the both of
us so you know I think honestly James
Corden gave us the best advice which is
go out there have the time of your lives
and if you do that people will have fun
too
[Music]
spirit total back
I know you guys got some awkward theater
geek photos whose was the most awkward
who really topped their is it there's a
photo of Josh that I want it tattooed on
my body that's a weird thing to say but
I love it you know which one she might
be talking about I dunno which one she's
talking about because my mom sent it to
me to send to the Tonys everybody in my
circle of friends said you have to use
this so have at it Internet if you were
going to belt out one word to describe
the feeling what would it be jubilant
stressed just being honest just being
honest
[Music]
[Applause]